now I'm gonna lie to you guys this movie
could land on one of two sides of Seth
MacFarlane's track record a coke for the
good one Ted - so Ted - is the
continuing Adventures of John and Ted
Ted being the talking teddy bear John me
and his best friend who wished him to
life as a kid played by Mark Wahlberg
generally speaking simplistically put
the government no longer sees Ted as a
person he is now an object he's property
he's a toy now they need to fight the
men and get his rights back that's
pretty much the gist
now you saw it in Ted one it still
sticks in Ted - Mark Wahlberg and Seth
MacFarlane have great chemistry as Ted
and John they have their back and forth
they had their ad libbing it works
really well in these Ted movies it's one
of those things where you look at even
if you hate it even if you think this
movie's a piece of you can at least
be like yeah they have great chemistry
this movie had some chuckles some
laugh-out-loud moments or a couple
moments I was like that was great some
cameos some work some I'm like that
you're relying so much on cameos the
ones really cool not gonna lie
to you on that Amanda Seyfried is
in this movie she's the lawyer helping
them out and you know there's gonna be
some love interesting going on between
her and Mark Wahlberg because Mila Kunis
is now gone they wrote her and she's
gone now which pretty much renders Ted
one obsolete it just doesn't matter she
was good in this movies she fit well in
the friend circle they made a good trio
when the jokes fall flat in this movie
they do kind of fall really flat what I
mean by that is this movie ultimately
suffers from laziness I call it sequel
itis sequel itis is a very common
condition among sequels where they kind
of do the same is the first movie
that are they throwing lazy ass jokes to
like everywhere right we don't need
brainstorming here's a movie spoof and
movies booths are fine I think movie
spooks are great they make me laugh but
when you're spoof is ultimately the
identical scene from the movie and the
senior spoofing it ultimately feels like
ripping it off
seriously they do that with
Jurassic Park in this movie and planes
trains and automobiles funny thing the
scene in planes trains and automobiles
that they spoof in this movie they
actually spooped in Family Guy I guess
Seth MacFarlane loves that scene and
keeping with the symptoms of sequel itis
Giovanni Ribisi sees in this movie to
ultimately play out the same scene he
didn't Ted one different coat of paint
but ultimately the same should happen
when I go to a comedy I go to laugh I
love to laugh it is literally my
favorite thing in life so
movie makes me laugh that's a win when
the movie makes me laugh really hard big
win this movie does both but it also
does that third thing that comedies
sometimes do where there's long
stretches of nothing really happening
that makes me laugh at all so rather
than laughing you're concentrating on
the plot of the movie and you're like is
anything cohesive happening right now
the movie literally goes from we want to
have kids to I'm not a person anymore to
a court case to a road trip this
goes everywhere and at a point you pull
back and you're like this has the
cohesive stitching of WarioWare if
you're a huge Seth MacFarlane fan this
is a win for you way better than a
million ways to die in the West I can
tell you that right now in the end I
will say Ted - pretty fun time if you're
drunk
yeah knows a party wait a minute I
should probably correct that right
now not going to I don't want to send
the wrong message to the children you
guys know alcohol is not what you're on
when you watch yourself MacFarlane thing
bites up Ted - have you seen it what did
you think about it what every thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more